the Brazilian President Jaya bolsa Nara
is visiting he's been called the Trump
of the tropics talks about putting
Brazil first of draining the swamp and
fighting socialism are we going to see
some kind of concrete agreement perhaps
on trade between President Trump and him
today well there will be some concrete
announcements there's no doubt about it
I won't step on the president's news
with with them but but basically we see
this is a big opportunity between the
two presidents obviously this is the
first time in a while that we've had an
eval idli pro-american Brazilian
president they see a lot of joint
economic opportunities this is a
possible political realignment within
the Western Hemisphere
but I think I think also on the global
stage that a more robust Brazil US
partnership will pay significant
dividends for both countries he has said
some controversial things in the past he
said that he'd rather his son died and
be homosexual he talks about a
congresswoman not deserving to be raped
because she was too ugly do you have
issues with any of those remarks look a
lot of people say things that that we
don't find attractive that they
themselves regret there are 193 members
of the United Nations I'll warrant you
that there's not one of the heads of
state of any of those countries that
hasn't said something objectionable what
we're dealing with or international
issues of strategic economic and
political concern to both countries you
said some of his comments are
unattractive others would cast them as
opponent look I don't think it's for
officials of our government to give
movie reviews or the performance of the
hundred and ninety-two other world
leaders on the world stage
everybody says things that somebody else
subjects to were not in the literary
criticism business we make our views
known on a lot of these issues privately
we've got important government to
government business to get on with
especially in the case of president
bowls and arrow who I think is prepared
to see a profound change in the
relationship between the United States
and Brazil we think that's all to the
good Trump in the tropics
accurate description bowls an arrow of
North America as we say about President
Trump this is a very exciting moment I
think we're going to see between the
leaders the two biggest democracies in
the Western Hemisphere
he has spoke fondly of military
dictatorship in the past of advocating a
torture you concerned about human rights
abuses well I think we're going to have
a lot of conversation about human rights
abuses particularly in Venezuela where
both leaders have a very strong
commitment to see representative
government restored to it to allow the
people to come out of the wreck of the
Chavez Maduro regime so I think that
will be a very significant part of the
conversation the situation in Venezuela
is dire the power is out we've seen
people drinking sewage water no supplies
in hospitals sanctions hasn't stopped
this one Guido seems to be losing some
momentum and president Maduro is not
moving a you closer now it's a military
action now I don't think we're closer to
military action although the president
is very clear that all options are on
the table remember there are roughly 40
to 50,000 American citizens in Venezuela
so we're concerned for them as well I
think actually momentum is moving in
Guido's direction I think Maduro showed
his true colors by blocking humanitarian
aid from coming across the border and
what you see unfolding in Venezuela
today is the collapse of a vibrant
economy and a vibrant democratic system
due to the policies they've pursued so
yes we've applied economic sanctions
against the regime to apply pressure to
bring this humanitarian tragedy to an
end as soon as we can president Maduro
has talked about civilians taking action
how bad does it have to get before you
do do something
well we're looking at a range of things
that we can do to put additional
pressure on the Maduro government we've
also helped the National Assembly and
the Opposition in president Guido in
speaking to military leaders and other
supporters of Maduro to say come over to
the opposition and this authoritarian
government the National Assembly has
promised amnesty the United States has
indicated we're willing to look past the
sanctions to do what we can to help
support president glide oh and what what
you don't see in the press reports is
there's a lot of conversation going on
behind the scenes one military leader
may look at another military leader and
not know what conversations that
person's having with the opposition so
there there's definitely a lot of
activity we just had one general defect
within the past few days we're expecting
others I've spoken to military defectors
but it's an issue of the senior military
leadership and whether or not they are
willing to abandon president Maduro
without that there's no chance of asking
him is there are you having
conversations privately with senior
military members have you had any
assurances that they are going to meet
the opposition is having countless
conversations and I can give you as
examples what's happened substantial
number of the families of the top
military leaders have left the country
some of them are in Miami summer in
Panama some in Cuba some in Spain but
that shows the confidence that the top
military officials have that they've
gotten their families out of the country
we believe their arrangements being made
for them to get their private wealth and
Swiss banks and other safe havens so
there's a lot going on not visible at
the surface that indicates continued
deterioration in maduras position what
about those Venezuelans who are in the
US illegally are you willing to give
them temporary protected status look
that's under discussion but I think at
the present moment what we ought to do
is Jim Baker always used to say is keep
our eyes on the prize and the prize is a
peaceful transition of power from Maduro
to glide oh what we'd like to see
Venezuelans who remain loyal to their
country can come back when freedom is
restored and help build the economy back
up previously you've advocated for
brexit of Britain now seems to be
teetering on the brink of constitutional
collapse this week are you having second
thoughts well you know if I were a
private citizen again I'd have a lot of
commentary on it I'll just say this the
president's been clear he wants a
resolution of this issue that allows the
United States and Britain to come to
trade deals again he sees huge
opportunity if Britain's status can be
resolved and I think the point he's made
that I would stress is people of Britain
have voted
when is the political class going to
give effect to that vote do you think a
trade deal is still in the offing
between the US we are ready to go we are
ready to go Trade Minister Liam Fox
would be welcome here any member the
government would be welcome here we can
do these deals quickly we're ready to go
we want to partner with a newly
independent Britain